the big bang no space total darkness
nothing
suddenly the universe Sparks into life
really
surely everyone knows you can't get
something from nothing
it's really the ultimate question how
did the universe come into being and the
thing is we don't want just everything
to come from nothing it seems like a
trick but here we are we exist so
something must have happened and we just
don't understand the physics of it yet
this is one of the big open questions in
cosmology the origin of the universe
and I think that people have variously
said stuff like oh the universe has come
from nothing like ta-da now there's a
universe but remember we don't have data
about the earliest moments of the
universe we don't know what was going on
we're struggling in the dark
to get insight into what may have
happened before the Big Bang that period
of apparent nothingness physicists look
to empty space
but does empty really mean there's
absolutely nothing there
it's not that there's something coming
from nothing because that old-fashioned
idea of nothing just doesn't apply to
what we think of as empty space
it turns out empty space is far from
empty the vacuum of Space is really a
rising sea a wash with charged Quantum
particles an electromagnetic fields
the vacuum of space itself can be a very
Dynamic thing matter can spontaneously
appear out of the vacuum and then a
spontaneously annihilate the vacuum is
full of particles and anti-particles
that are whizzing into existence and
then disappearing colliding with each
other
space is full of virtual particles
popping in and out of existence
and there's no question that they're
real their effects are absolutely
visible we can see them
in extreme physics things can get
strange
maybe nothing is something after all
if empty space contains particles that
apparently come from nothing could some
sort of similar process have triggered
the Big Bang
the quantum vacuum itself can randomly
spontaneously without any input just
have a lot of energy perhaps enough
energy to spark something that we would
call a big bang
there are many speculative theories
about the origin of the universe
but is its sudden appearance out of
nothingness the only trick had pulled
off
it also made matter from energy the
universe is full of galaxies stars
planets and comets where did they all
come from According to the Big Bang
narrative from one tiny dot when the
universe began there was actually no
room for matter at all the temperature
was so high the spaces were so
compressed that matter couldn't exist
so how did the universe manage to become
full of matter
in the Primeval Atom there was no room
for matter but it was crammed full of
energy
and as Einstein tells us all we need to
create matter is energy
according to E equals
squared energy and matter are
interchangeable
Einstein taught us special relativity
that energy in matter are two sides of
the same coin you can convert matter
into energy by say blowing something up
the most fearsome example of converting
matter into energy was the atomic bomb
developed in the 1940s
but with the big bang this process was
reversed energy created matter
that expanded out and out to fill a
whole universe
and in Cosmic terms the universe where
matter would develop grew remarkably
fast
right after the universe was born it had
an unbelievable growth spurt basically
going from being a toddler to a teenager
in the single tick of a clock
how could the universe get so big so
quickly if we believe the Big Bang story
it appears to have broken one of the
most fundamental laws of physics
[Music]
did the early Universe really grow
faster than the speed of light
parts of the universe that are now
separated by 93 billion light years once
had the same Cosmic zip code
to have expanded so quickly inflation
must have broken one of the fundamental
rules of physics
we all know that one rule the universe
sticks to all the time is that nothing
can travel faster than the speed of
light so how can we possibly say that
the Universe expanded faster than the
speed of light
but inflation says the universe expands
into nothingness there was no outside of
the universe the universe was everything
so space itself was inflating and space
can move as fast as it wants it can't go
faster than the speed light through
space but space itself is allowed to
stretch and expand as fast as it wants
and that's what our universe is doing
the idea of inflation Smooths out the
universe and in kind of a peculiar way
you can kind of think of it as having a
sheet with a lot of wrinkles in it and
if you take that sheet and snap it
really hard those wrinkles very suddenly
flatten out the theory of inflation is
one of the craziest sounding ideas in
the history of science
so crazy that it might just be right
inflation helps us to understand the
inexplicable but there's a problem we
don't know what triggered or powered
inflation
the inflationary Universe idea imagines
that the Universe was suffused with some
kind of ultra dense energy at Early
times something that pushed the universe
apart what caused there to be that hot
expanding stuff
we have to be humble and acknowledge
that we don't know for sure
but whatever started it inflation was
over in a split second it didn't last
very long and this is
difficult to understand how did
inflation stop
we don't know
we got none folks well we got some
things but
it's tough it's tough
[Music]
it's tough but has the process of
inflation really stopped
[Music]
one radical theory proposes if the force
called inflation
kick-started the expansion of one
Universe then why not another and
another
and another
is inflation creating a whole series of
new universes
is there a Multiverse